John blit who works for us he has these
little dinner parties with Jason where
Jason gorges himself on all kind of
drinking and all this [ __ ] you know they
get the crazy so John Jason Gary
Dell'Abate and Chris Wilding they were
all together eating Jason started puking
oh my goodness it turns out he's
allergic to crab and maybe some crab was
in this dish in the dish well it was
lobster but they think that sometimes
the crabs are near the lobsters this is
Jason puking he's in John's apartment
right in the bathroom and I couldn't
even get the the bathroom door closed
behind me to throw up so half my body
was still in the kitchen Wow then they
got in an uber went to the hospital Wow
and in the uber he was throwing up he
pulled over the side you are here's the
uber ready dip your head out too far
okay just keep your head talked a little
bit buddy oh and there's nothing coming
out there's having an allergic reaction
to
here's why I'm angry you guys you know
this whole coronavirus is going on
you bring him to the emergency room you
[ __ ] are all sitting in a hospital
the worst place to be right now is a
hospital for coronavirus No
yeah just roll him out onto the [ __ ]
floor and there's somebody that needs
out yeah Gary
so glad I wasn't with you sir big boy
one sight once I saw you were admitted
I'd leave Howard he was battling he was
wobbling he really was so what do you
think you're allergic to crab why no I'm
allergic to crab I mean III diagnosed
with that so obviously either there was
crab in there or you were just being
gluttonous and you got sick no Howard it
was poison I was poisoned the de pavo
because they did it at the hospital they
took my blood they checked everything
they pumped me up full of steroids
it was absolutely food poisoning how Jon
put crab in there no I think what
happened to lady trying to kill you
the lady was explained because this is
not the first time this has happened the
last time happened was about three years
ago where I had something I didn't know
how crab in it and she said it gets more
and more sensitive so if somebody has
crammed on their breath and I smell it
it could put me into anaphylactic shock
really so she was saying that somebody
could have touched the crab at the store
and then picked up the lobster and that
would have been enough Wow do you carry
one of those epi pens oh my god I signed
one now yeah then I picked one up
there's in my it's in my bag right now
cool cool yes yeah let's look fabulous
getting like hot and cold shakes and he
was breathing really heavy I mean I
thought if nothing else you might have a
heart attack right right yeah it's like
your whole body is rejecting you it's
like everything feels the opposite of
what it should feel I'm sweating like
I'm in the middle of the desert and I'm
shivering like I'm in the middle of
Antarctic the other weird thing was I
noticed when Jason was laying down and
you might have noticed this when you
went to clean your clothes the next day
the bottom of Jason's pants they were
covered in puke
I mean it's a small apartment you can
smell it you can hear every where ruin
the dinner yeah I mean I apologize yeah
my I don't want to freak you guys out
but any article you read right now talks
about the last place to go in the
hospital so the chances of them bringing
it into the studio is extremely no I
what were you in New York City I was
like Gary and Kris should have stayed
the [ __ ] out of the hospital you did
scrub yourself down cleany lord I mean
of course Gary's gonna be patient zero
here you know well Gary was do wanna
come a meet and greet at the hospital
it's shaking hands
I get a lot of fans oh hello everyone
that's me guys oh btw
Babu is here one of the nurses
recognized me she was asking me I knew
her dad from college excuse me did your
father click but I don't know he went to
a bill fire I just thought I felt very
great [ __ ] over there waiting for it
like an uber driver ain't gonna treat
him I gotta say that uber one of the
issues over was they're pretty quick us
figuring out where the [ __ ] to go is
what's a call that's why you call an
ambulance what a guy like that and then
you uh geniuses who work with me
wouldn't been in an emergency room for a
couple hours being exposed to everyone
coughing all right all three you get out
of here